So if you have custom word lists that you manage, go take these right now and add them to your
custom word list because they're known good files that have leaked passwords in the past.
Best part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
One of the cool things about going to these live hacking events is the ability to look at what you
found and what other people have found and understand where the holes are in your methodology,
right? By comparing notes. And thanks to Adobe sponsoring this episode today. We have an
opportunity very similar to that for you guys. Okay. So here's how this is going to work.
Adobe has agreed to give you guys a 10% one-time bonus on your first valid report to any of the
following products. Listen closely. Adobe Behance, Adobe Portfolio, Adobe Fonts, Acrobat Web. Okay.
Those four. And to get that, you have to use the code CTBBP0907. Okay. The description will have
that information. Also, this is a valid through September 7th, right? So keep that in mind. Then
what we're going to do on top of that is we're going to do a hack along in the CTPP discord for
everybody. Okay. And we're going to start looking at these targets. And so what will happen then is
you guys will take a look at it. You'll see what you can find. Then we'll do the hack along and everybody
will be hacking on them, finding vulnerabilities. I'll be hacking on them, finding vulnerabilities.
And then we can compare notes and see where we missed the sketchy pieces of information or the
leads or the vulnerabilities themselves. Okay. So really good opportunity. This is the kind of stuff
that we have at live hacking events and Adobe is bringing this to you guys. So definitely check out
those targets. They're in the description along with the code. Also, the Adobe team wants me to let you
know that they're going to be at besides Las Vegas sponsoring August 4th, August 5th. Come check it out,
go to their booth, have a chat with them. They'll also be at Defcon in the bug bounty village. So if you
see anybody with like Adobe swag or whatever, don't hesitate to come up and say hi. All right. That's
it. Thank you, Adobe. Back to the show.
Yo, what's up, dude? I got to tune in on your hack along this morning and it seemed like it was going
uh, pretty well. And then you told me right after I hopped off, you all found a bunch of bugs. So if
people are not, uh, in critical thinking doing hack alongs, they should hop in there.
Dude, it was a lot of fun. And every, every time we do those things, it's not me fighting the bugs.
Typically it's the people in the, in the chat. Like I'm over just kind of like, you know, screwing
around with something and, and typically like I'll find a bug or I'll find, um, you know, at least some
good gadgets or some fun functionality. Um, but almost every single time we, we, we do the hack along,
somebody finds a bug, a portable bug. Um, but yeah, this time I did find some, some cool stuff and, uh,
Bebex shout out to Bebex found a couple XSS. And so, you know, we have some results from this one.
Yeah. That's amazing. I, um, I thought that that was interesting. I w the way that
you like went down that initial rabbit hole on that random domain. So yeah. Yeah. It's, it's,
it's fun, dude. It's fun. I mean, like I, I, I wish I could say it perfectly represents hacking.
Cause it, it, it doesn't, you know, when, when you're trying to do a stream and you're trying to,
you know, um, talk, manage chat. Yeah, exactly. You're trying to manage chat. You're trying to,
you know, like for me, it's very hard to hack and talk at the same time. I'm getting better at it.
You've definitely gotten better at it since we started critical thinking, but, um, it's very
hard. Uh, and I definitely feel my processing power go down. Um, yeah, but let me, let me ask you an
interesting question. Let's say that you said, Hey, we're gonna take those same people and let them all
hack for an hour. You plus them. Do you think you would find more bugs doing the hack along collectively,
or would the, you plus those people all hacking for an hour and a half, find more bugs independently?
I, I have a very strong opinion here. I have a very strong opinion. Yeah. I don't know, man,
you know how I do. I, I do prefer, I do love the power of just focus and sitting down and like locking
in and, and stuff like that. But definitely, you know, when with the collective brain of everybody,
you know, everybody's gonna see something a little bit different and somebody's gonna have that eye to
pull out, you know, a crazy, crazy end points or, uh, quirk or API key or something like that.
So I think that you, I think that collectively there's way more bugs found during hack along
even with the level of talent that was there. And I think that it's because, um, there's like this
shared perception sense where like you're handing off gadgets to people who are the best at those
gadgets naturally, because like when someone's paying attention to the stream and they see something
that they're like kind of a pseudo expert at, they're gonna like key in on that. And then when
people find things that you're particularly good at, they surface it to you and then you go look at it.
So anyways, I think it's really cool. I think more people should do more hack alongs.
Well, I was going to say, you know, there I'll give a shout out to demo and, and, uh,
You mean turbo? Yeah, turbo, exactly. Demo, turbo. My boy needs to get his aliases in place, but, um,
Demo is there for every hack along and, and he, um, he always finds some crazy stuff, you know, that I,
that I missed and, uh, yeah, and he's going to be doing a talk at, uh, bug bunny village under the alias
turbo with seven for the team on Saturday at noon. Yeah. On Saturday at noon. Um, so definitely check that
out. It's going to be awesome. Um, he is very high skill hacker. Um, but yeah, man, I, I've always,
I've always been impressed by the hack alongs. It's fun time, but we have a ton of content to get
to today. So let's jump into that. Um, since we've got a lot of guest episodes, this one's going to be
more of like a news catch up episode. Um, cause we had the Valentino episode. We've got Jurado coming
soon. We've got some others coming up. Are you just leaking our whole calendar right now, dude?
Valentino came out today. I leaked one person and you already mentioned that last time.
I didn't mention it last time. Did I mention it last time?
I don't know, but I told people, I told personal people that I thought it was coming
out this week and I was wrong. So hopefully it comes out next week.
Yeah. Well, I'm going to shuffle them around a little bit. So anyway, all right, fine. We,
we do have an expo related episode in the queue. It is already recorded. It is going to come out
eventually, but we're, we're working on some of the details. So, um, all right, let's, let's get
to some of the content here. Um, there was a, a writeup that surfaced, uh, not too long ago. Um,
that was back from 2019. And, uh, I want to say it was Victor. I forget the last name, but, uh, that,
that tweeted about it and kind of brought it up from the dead. Uh, and I, I just wanted to highlight
it on the pod because I really like this type of vulnerability. This is a, um, instance metadata
service protection bypass in Google cloud. And for any of you guys that know, you know, about, uh, metadata
URLs, this is a huge part of, uh, SSRF exploitation in a cloud environment where, um, you know, you often
will hit these metadata URLs and get back instance, uh, metadata about the, the given instance you're
on in, in a cloud environment. Um, and there have been some protections that have been put in place by,
by Google and by AWS now, um, to prevent us from hitting those, uh, metadata URLs as easily.
Um, and this vulnerability from 2019 was when that those protections first came out, the metadata flavor,
um, header being required, which you often can't specify in an SSRF environment.
Um, and it was three bypasses to that behavior. Uh, the, the first one, um, was simply by adding an
extra slash to the URL, uh, under compute metadata. So compute metadata slash slash V1 slash instance slash
name, um, which is just so dumb. Insane. Insane. Unbelievably dumb. Uh, like why, how does that,
how does that affect whether checking for the header or not? That doesn't make any sense.
Like some sort of reverse proxy middleware must be, you know, which is very telling about the
implementation of this at GCP. Um, then he does it again with HTTP one. Then he does it again with
just a random semi-colon in the URL. Um, and so each of those were accepted by, by, um, by Google
VRP and paid a bounty. And I just wanted to highlight them because, you know, you definitely want to spend
time fuzzing these things in all sorts of ways, adding slashes, adding semi-colons, trying HTTP zero,
especially when it's high impact pieces of, of architecture, like the metadata URL. Um, these
are the things we must know about. And if this person had kept this in their pocket for a long time,
so many vulnerabilities. Yeah. That's what I was thinking. This feels almost like a bad move.
You know, like, I, like, I totally get reporting it. Um, and I, and I wouldn't tell them to do anything
but report it, but like if a malicious actor got ahold of this, that would be a very different story.
Yeah. Farmable bug. Um, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Very exploitable. So definitely high impact stuff found here. And I think that sort of attack
scope is really interesting for cloud environments.
Yeah. It makes me wonder how many things like this are out there. I'm sure there are plenty.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Sweet. Um, we can jump to one of my smaller ones.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. Um, our friend, Ian Carroll and Sam Curry, uh, released a blog post like yesterday or the day
before across a few different social media platforms. I'll share my screen as I click through this real
quick. It's called, would you like an eye door with that? Makes me think of the song. Do you know that,
you know, the old McDonald's song, the rap, the what, the rap, the McDonald's rap, like a double
cheeseburger and hold the lettuce. Don't be front and sun. No seas. Makes me think of that.
I haven't heard that in forever. That's such a throwback. Wow.
Yeah. All right. Here we go. Um, it's probably kind of wide, I guess more. Um, yeah. So they
titled their blog post, would you like an eye door with that leaking 64 million McDonald's job
applications? Yeah. So basically the prospective employees who want to like get hired by McDonald's
can chat with this chatbot called Olivia and it's made by this company called Paradox AI. And so
that's actually probably where the vulnerability really was, but, um, essentially it's like not that
interesting of a bug. It's just an eye door, but their, their process of finding it was interesting.
And it involved having default credentials of one to six as both the username and the password,
but, um, but yeah, so like they got in from the admin side and then they also applied for it
from the user side. And then eventually from the user side, they saw this, uh,
put request that involved, uh, a lead ID and their lead ID was 64 million. So they just,
they decremented it and, uh, found other users, actual like phone numbers and actual like the
conversations with the AI agent. So I have a theory here. I wonder if this is not just McHires.
I think it's like the entire Paradox AI database, um, because 64 million is a lot, even for McDonald's.
Like how many employees did McDonald's even have? Yeah, that's like a bit of the US, like, like,
applying for a job at McDonald's. I don't think that's right.
Right. Like, uh, they have 2 million people worldwide. And so, I mean, I guess they could
have some turnover and it could add up that amount. I mean, there's, even if it is the third party,
McDonald's is probably their biggest, um, vendor or whatever that like their biggest customer. But
anyways, I thought it was really interesting. And if you think about it, I was like, man,
this is an AI system that has had 64 million unique users or 64 million, you know, cases or whatever.
Outside of the major providers and maybe like cursor and stuff. I wonder if this is like one of the
most used AI apps. They said they tried prompt injection and it was like really, really railroaded.
Like it didn't, it couldn't do anything interesting. So it might not even be like an LLM backed app. It
could just be, you know, those old agent systems that like AWS and GCP and everything had even before
LLMs where it was like a support, you know, a railroaded support system. But right.
Anyways, I thought it was interesting. Yeah, that is definitely an interesting one. I, I, uh, I hate,
hate to see the default credentials of one, two, three, four, five, six, uh, for a system that sensitive.
I mean, come on. Yeah. That's a pretty egregious. Not gonna lie. Um, but very cool. Nonetheless,
I love the little stunt hacks that, uh, that Sam and Ian do for fun that they just pwn some company
completely. Um, and sometimes it's as simple as like, you know, an ID or here, or sometimes it's
like all the crazy stuff they throw together. Yeah. Like all the car hacks. I mean, that stuff is
really, really valuable. Like this one I think is more for fun, but when you think about the stuff
they've done, they've done for the airline industry and the car industry, I think it makes
like a really material difference to like all of our lives when they're responsibly disclosing that
stuff. So a hundred percent, man, definitely, definitely securing stuff up a lot. Um, okay.
So next on the list is Christmas in July with Searchlight Cyber. Um, the Searchlight Cyber team is
releasing a bunch of research in July, which is super cool. Yeah. Um, they're two in,
so we'll cover those now, uh, as we're recording and then hopefully we'll cover the other ones before
DEF CON. Um, but this first one was how we got precision XSS on every AM cloud site thrice,
which is, which is lit. Um, and there were a couple of things I wanted to highlight from this one. Um,
the first one is, is that I think that this is a really cool technique that they're using here that, um,
we've kind of discussed a bit in the research lab for critical thinking. Um, and it, we're, and we call
these sort of cross customer vulnerabilities, right? Where, where, um, there's, you know, you're able to host
something, uh, in this specific scenario, they're, they're referencing an NPM package, right? That,
and they're loading JS from it, but you're able to host something on a different, um, service. And then
the thing you're attacking has like a reverse proxy, uh, to that service, um, for the purpose of grabbing
data related to the user itself. Um, but actually you can reference, you know, some other user of
that service and, and, and pull down some data. Um, so, so what, what's happening here is, uh, they
have this path on AM cloud that's supposed to serve JS files from, from the JS CDN. Yep. And they found
that you're able to upload HTML files to that CDN and then reference those HTML files underneath the path
of every single AM cloud site. Um, and, and I'll just read this little, this little snippet here
to make sure I'm, I'm extra clear about it while doing bug bounty on a site running a, uh, AM. We
noticed that the site was loading some JavaScript from the route slash dot rum at Adobe helix rum
dist slash rum standalone dot JS. Further digging indicated that the slash dot rum path was handled
by Adobe's cloud specific CDN configuration and appeared to be proxying directly to the NPM package host.
Our interest was peaked as NPM packages can contain HTML files. They may allow for an XSS. And I just
think that is such a beautiful example of very ingenuity of attack vector ideation.
Yeah. In fact, I think like the frame here that everyone should be taking away from this is like,
if you have some sort of SAS, like that allows you to, you know, spin up your own tenant or your own
host. So there's a million of those, right? Like work day service now Salesforce, but then the list is
like nearly infinite. There are thousands. And then if they, in any point are using stuff hosted on like
a third party or domain or a CDN domain, and not only your sub domain. So you could literally go hunt for
this by just looking for apps that have a lot of functionality where you can upload things or modify a
lot of content. And then just see if they get hosted on a shared domain that the other customers use as well.
Now all of a sudden you have like a really strong gadget that would end up doing something like this.
Absolutely. Yeah. And so I think just from the start, you know, the kind of vulnerabilities that the
searchlight cyber team here looking for just very good. And this is how you do, you know, really
impactful security research here. And then they take that and, you know, they validate their assumption.
They were able to pop, you know, the XSS on unpackage that was happily serving text HTML content type.
And then they go and look at the logic of how exactly this, you know, route is being essentially
remapped to the CDN. And as they're going through here, they find three different bypasses. One
is a missing slash at the end of a path that uses path.startswith. Pretty classic vulnerability.
But the other ones are a lot more interesting, I thought. After it was patched, they actually ended up
using a technique that I think is really widely applicable, which is the fact that fetch
will take any new line or tab character that's in a URL and just remove it. So if you do dot tab dot slash,
that will become a path traversal. So let's say there's some logic that's checking for dot dot slash
before you know, it passes to fetch. You can pass in dot, you know, actual tab character dot slash, and then it will pass the regex.
But then when it gets to fetch that side, the tab will be deleted and it will do the normalization.
That's like a relatively big deal. Yeah. Have you ever used that before?
I think I have used it without realizing what was happening.
I found organically just by fuzzing, looking for character is what works, what doesn't. Yeah.
Yeah. And they, you know, they traced it all the way down to, um, let's see this at a URL parser library.
Um, and then mentioned that, uh, you know, fetch was utilizing this. So, um, with that,
they were able to bypass again. And then, um, they were also able to utilize some, um, normalization
gadgets, um, within that reverse or the reverse proxy environment where, you know, you'll hit,
hit a specific path that three O twos, but when a three O twos, it actually normalizes part of your,
URL encoded, um, content. So yeah, really, really cool stuff that they're, that they're doing there.
And I think a lot of those techniques are, are really, um, applicable, uh, to, to other sort of exploitation scenarios.
Yeah. You've been all about this. I feel like on the hack along today,
you were also talking a lot about this, like, just like when it comes to string parsing, all the different
unique characters you can fuzz for or test for, or, you know, break out of like, I, I feel like
that's almost like the, the core part of hacking that you kind of think about these days.
Yeah. I think about it a lot. It's, it's very interesting. And I did have one more thing I
wanted to mention on this before we moved to the next one. Um, see if I can find it right here.
I gotta search for it, but the way that they got this to work was super awesome. Um, oh, here it is
right here. So there were two, um, CDNs, JavaScript CDNs that were serving these JS files. Yeah.
Um, but only one of them work only unpackage served to the HTML content type. JS deliver did not. And so,
uh, they found that it was actually caching the response, but they didn't want the incorrect,
uh, you know, response to get cached. Yeah. And so they went to the,
like they kept researching until they found a way, a difference between JS deliver and unpackage that
would force it to, to not be cached. Oh my goodness. Like a cache difference between the two servers.
Yes. And they, on JS deliver, if you put all caps in the name, it's, it's case sensitive. So it would
404, but on unpackage, it's not case sensitive. So you put all caps. Yeah. And it would get the response.
So that's awesome. Uh, it was freaking beautiful, man. Bravo to the searchlight cyber team again,
who is doing the majority of the hacking there. Obviously shoves does, but who else do you know?
Yeah. Jeez. I mean, this, the guy that wrote this one is Adam Cuez. Um, so I'm not sure. I'm not sure
who exactly is doing that. I know shoves does have his hands on all of this. And I imagine since
the beginning of this was, uh, from bug bounty. Um, then it, it, it was probably related to that.
Yeah. I heard, uh, Sheps mentioned Adam a lot, so I'm sure he's one of the main guys. Yeah. Sweet. Um,
one, this little really small thing here was the, just a tweet from James Kettle. Um, and he was
talking about how Google docs support exporting as Markdown. They've had paste as Markdown for a while,
but now that you can, you can export as Markdown, you can use like really nice, um,
like auto formatters that will just change like Markdown to HTML or whatever. So, um, yeah,
really nice. I personally really love Markdown. I love just plain text files. So if you, you know,
that's a common thing that a lot of bug bounty hunters are using for their notes or whatever.
Oh dude, I'm, I'm glad you mentioned that. Cause that's like kind of like a tool, right? Um,
not as much as like a hacking technique. And I actually had something that I wanted to bring up
related to that. Um, I use that feature all the time, by the way, the copy is Markdown. Like they didn't,
I didn't even see like a change log or anything. I just right clicked one day and I was like,
Oh, no way. Copy is Markdown. Um, so that's awesome. But the one that I was going to tell you
about was Raycast for windows, man. Raycast came out on windows. Yes. It came out on windows.
Are you using it? I've got it already. I've got it. Yeah. And guess what?
Did you convert like your whole stack to it yet or what?
I did. I converted my stack to it. I've got all of my, like URL encoding stuff, all of my like quick
clipboard operation. How long did it take it into Raycast? Uh, with AI, not very long, couple hours.
Okay. Um, but it's, it's pretty great. Uh, there definitely are going to be some improvements that
are needed, but the, the Raycast team is moving pretty fast and they gave me, um, they gave me 15, uh,
windows invites to give out. Oh, that's awesome. To the beta. So, uh, I don't know. How should we do
this? Should we say like, um, maybe I'll put out a tweet, um, uh, on, or no, no, no, I'll put it in
the discord. I'll put something in the discord. It says, Hey, you know, respond to this message and,
uh, we'll get you, you know, one of the windows invites if you want. Um, so Richard remind me to do
that. I don't want to write it down right now, but, uh, we'll definitely put that out there if you
guys want access to Raycast for windows. I had one more kind of small toolsy thing before we go to
another one. Um, basically I saw someone tweet that, you know, it's better prompting etiquette to,
um, say like name of assistant does X instead of, uh, you know, you do X because, uh, you know,
model providers like Claude do this. Um, like they, they, in their instructions, they like, Claude does
this, Claude does that, Claude does this. And I thought that was really interesting. Wow.
So I'm going to phone call. There's really loud in my ears. Um, and, um, so someone else was like,
Oh, that's so obvious. And so then that person had like a big following. So then they quote to you
like with like a survey that was like, do you in your prompt ejection or jail breaks or whatever,
or just in your system prompts put like, you know, the app name does X or you do X. And like,
it was 95% that like you do. And I noticed in my, and I use, I noticed in my prompting,
I always do that. Like you should respond this way. You should do that. And, um, the fact that
Anthropic who's done like, you know, probably more studies on this than anyone is using it the other
way. I think it's actually great to do it the other way. And so anyways, as you're hacking,
as you're using prompt injection payloads, as you're using the jail breaks, whatever,
if you know the system, which you often do, like, let's say you're hacking on Google,
you would say Gemini does this or Gemini responds this way or what have you. Or at the very least,
just try both because if in their system prompt, it's like all, you know, first person, Claude does
this, then you switch it to second person and say, you do this. It's going to be very obvious to the
model to know that that's not, huh? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Second person's you. Right. Second person's you.
Third person is Claude, right? Right. Yeah. So it'd be third person. Yeah. So if the system prompt is in
third person and then you switch to second, it's going to probably be jarring to the model and it'll be
little no. Whereas if you try third person, then all of a sudden, yeah, actually, I wonder if any of
them do use first person. Like if they say something like, I really like to respond with all caps and I
really know a lot about this and it's like internal system prompt. It kind of makes sense though. If you
think about how it's processing at inference, because that's how our thoughts are sometimes. Anyways,
random little prompting technique there. That is nice. I like that. Yeah. It makes sense that you should
match what the system prompt is, especially if you want to blend in with the system prompt. Yeah. And if you don't know,
just try both. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Good shit. All right. Next up, back to Searchlight Cyber,
Christmas in July. Their write up was entitled "Abusing Windows.net Quarks in Unicode Normalization
to Exploit .NET Nuke." And so essentially the concept here is they've been kind of exploiting some
vulnerabilities lately, it seems, with file.exists, which will make, which when you can provide an absolute
path to it, will connect to a Windows share and leak the NTLM hash, right? Classic technique.
Yep.
And so they're doing a little research on how exactly all that works. They found an
unauthenticated endpoint on .NET Nuke that will handle a file upload. And there's a bunch of
restrictions in place on this. It takes any special character and it removes it with a regex and puts it
as an underscore, it cleans up the file name, it validates the characters. Excuse me. But then
right here at the very end, after all of that sanitization, it does utility.convertUnicodeCharacters
and then passes in the file name, which is just lovely. And essentially what's happening here is
after all of the sanitization, they do Unicode normalization, which will, can allow you to just
take, you know, Unicode characters like... Oh, rip. It should have been at the beginning, right? Oh, man.
Exactly. It take full with dot and convert it into a dot, you know, do whatever, right?
So the team was able to utilize this to exploit and get an NTLM auth hash leak, which I thought was
pretty awesome. So I always want to shout that out. Order of sanitization is really important.
And as I was sort of reading the code for this, I'll put it up on the screen here. You can see that
the convertUnicodeCharacters function here does a bunch of regular expression to convert Unicode
characters. And then right here, it just sort of does a general conversion.
Mm-hmm.
But one of the things that was really interesting to me was this piece down here at the end, which
replaces question marks with string empty, tabs with string empty, slash R with string empty,
backslash N as string empty, right? And any time I see something getting moved to, you know,
getting replaced to string empty, I think, oh, I need to be using that as a way to bypass stuff.
For example, like what we talked about earlier with, you know, dot, tab, dot, right?
That's exactly where my mind went. It's like, oh, that's like very similar code to that thing we
were just talking about.
Exactly, exactly. And if you look earlier up, you know, they cover this because you can only have one
dot in this whole string anyway. So it's covered in this scenario, but I wanted to just shout it out
again is that, you know, in these replacement scenarios where there's taking some sensitive
or malicious string potentially and replacing it with empty, you definitely have to be able to
utilize that as an attacker sometimes to get path traversal or sneak in some character sequences that
have meaning to the application.
Yep. Yeah, makes sense.
Yeah, really good article. Let me see if I had anything else on all of that.
Yeah, I mean, it was it was a pretty clean one. I mean, the the NTLM hash leak strategy, you know,
if you're not familiar with that, you must know what that does. So definitely research that if you're
not order of operations in in sanitization, and then look for replaces to empty strings that you can use
to sneak in malicious character sequences. All right. Yeah, I really need to I really need to look
for more Unicode normalization stuff. It's always like, like, it feels like one of the purest forms
of hacking, like it just feels so cool. And you're always talking about it. And so I just need to find
it's great. It's really fun. Okay, so let's do I'll do my big, I'll do my bigger one since we're
earlier in the episode. This is like really high quality content for everybody. So let me share my
screen for the viewers. Oh, by the way, I saw you mentioning earlier on the hack along the like top
podcast thing for Spotify. I didn't even know that we were on Spotify. I just always use YouTube or for
my podcast listening. I use overcast or Apple podcasts. So kind of interesting. We have a lot of
reviews on there. We have like 405 reviews or something. So yeah, dude, I think last time I
checked, I think we're around like the 200 or something like that. 200 largest 200th largest
technology podcast. That's awesome. And I'm sure it's I want to get up there. Yeah, like I saw like
Lex Friedman there. It's like, it's kind of a technology podcast, but that's more like a catchall.
So there's probably, you know, a good number in there that are more catchalls that just happen to
cover tech. So it's pretty sweet. Yeah, there's some there's some ones up there,
though, like hacked and stuff like that that are relating to hacking and Darknet Diaries, of course,
that are hacking related. But we are so niche in the bug bounty world. And we do really, you know,
push into that niche pretty hard. We don't really stray from that niche very much. So
yeah, which I think that's perfect. Like if we went way more vague, it'd be so much less
actionable for our listeners. So we'll keep it that way.
Yeah. So the TLDR on this is literally at the top. And so I'm just going to read it for the audio
listeners. But this is a post. Yeah, this is a post by Sharon Brizdanoff called titled How I
scanned all of GitHub's oops commits for leak secrets. And the TLDR here, we'll summarize it. And then I'll
hit a few high points. Basically, GitHub archive is a website which logs every public commit,
even the ones that developers try to delete. And so that is a result of what is called push events.
You can just query and I'll do that later, maybe even on screen for the viewers, all GitHub events,
just like they're just like streaming out of GitHub all the time. And a guy made a thing called a GitHub
archive like 11 years ago, and it's it's archived every single every single event. And so even if you
force delete a specific commit, if it was on a public repo, it's in there forever, basically. So it's
kind of scary. But anyways, he scanned all of those are called zero commit force push events.
Since 2020 and uncovered secrets worth 25,000 to bug money. Honestly, there's probably way more in
there. He's still going through them. But together with Truffle security, they're actually open sourcing
a tool so that you can scan your own GitHub org for those. Sweet. Yeah, pretty sweet. So that's
the TLDR. The main points that I wanted to hit was this quote here where it says he's the one who did
the last one where he was called like how I made 64,000 from deleted files. And if anyone doesn't know
the Sharon was on the podcast, so just Google Sharon Briz, Briz, Briz and off Briz and off. Yeah. And you
can find his episode. But in his previous one, how I made 64 K from deleted files, he talked about
orphaned blobs. But in this case, there are also a thing called orphan commits. And so basically,
whenever you change the head. So this is kind of a get nerd thing in get whenever you switch the head to
the previous commit and then force push that it basically deletes the pointer to the previous commit
that you did. So that you can't find it in get log, you can't find it in your get commit history, you
can't find it in get tree, there's like no way to find it. But that doesn't mean it doesn't still
exist. And it is like a long new ID. So it's an unguessable ID or what you know, I'm kind of famous
for. I've got the blog post on why I think unguessable ID ors are still ID ors. And so it's kind of like
that's the thing called GitHub archive. So this is such freaking good research, man. This is classic Sharon. This is great. Yeah. So let me go down here because I the GitHub archive bit is really interesting. Right here. So eventually I came up with a simple idea. I will use the GitHub event API alongside the GitHub archive project to scan all zero commit push events, aka deleted commits for secrets. And so there is a proper way to leave this just as like a really random tidbit. Don't
don't do don't move your head and then do a get force push. You have to use what's called like get filter or something like that. I don't know if they even cover it in here. But if you ask top AI models today, they'll tell you because I was like, Oh, man, how common is this for it for it to recommend? So yeah, here's what he says a lot of people would do to blow away commits. They would do get reset hard head minus one and then push then force push that to the origin. But this is the wrong way to do it. And the better way is called get filter or something. So anyways, this GitHub archive is really neat. So
So I'm going to switch to that tab. So the GitHub archive is, you know, a project to record all the public GitHub timeline archive it and make it easily accessible. So first of all, extremely cool project. And the fact that this has been running since 2011 is amazing, and probably like an incredible way to do security research if people ever want to do this, this may have even been the way that some people are that like remember whenever shubs his team,
made those word lists. He may have used this. I'm not sure. I don't remember. But anyways, so let me actually show you the way that you can pull current events from
Is this like the stream of events?
Yeah, so right now just in your terminal go curl HTTPS colon slash slash API without any no auth api.github.com slash events, dude, what the heck it's just scrolling. Yeah. So so cool. Super interesting. Super cool. Yeah. I don't know what all you can do with this. But anyways, we've been talking about this too long. So I'll just I'll speed run this. Basically, they did this for all repos over the current.
colon slash slash API without any no off api.github.com slash events dude what the heck it's
just scrolling yeah so so cool super interesting super cool yeah i don't know what all you can do
with this but anyways uh yeah we've been talking about this too long so i'll just i'll speed run
this basically they did this for all repos over the across the last 14 years and found bukuza
secrets and then there was like well how are we going to like actually filter through these
so they built automation that would automatically hunt for more impactful secrets and then they
manually tested them like the ones that are like uh important you know they use things like secret
ninja and other stuff but then what i thought was really cool they didn't release this but they
are they vibe coded up their own little like secret triage thing that would then validate some of these
because obviously the majority of these can be validated in an automated fashion and they haven't
released that or uh shared more about it yet but they said that they would i'm pretty positive in here
but anyways let me show you these so these are secrets over time so they trend upwards make sense as
more people commit and then also as these old ones kind of um get dropped off or rotated or whatever
but um the vast majority of secrets were mongo db but i mean even these small percentages are so many
that it's still a lot so like the there was 130 aws keys oh my god yeah they so it said they said the
mongo db is probably um just like students leaking non-interesting side projects so that's not that
big of a deal but they but the github pat tokens and the aws credentials were like obviously extremely
beneficial and generated the highest bounties um there was one more thing okay yeah my favorite
thing about this entire post because you know i love fuzzing is they leak or they list the most
leaky file names it's a list of like 30 file names here i immediately added these to all of my word
lists and i was missing like over half of them so if you have custom word lists that you manage go take
these right now and add them to your custom word list because they're known good files that have
leaked passwords in the past dude what the heck why is just the the path unknown in there why that is
not even when i would check like that's crazy wow dude yeah i mean like they have read me in here so
be careful like if you don't want noisy like if you pick read me it's going to find a bunch of stuff but
if you're doing any kind of secret scanning or secret testing like it makes sense right people
would just throw their keys and read me or throw in their example they accidentally copy and paste
in a full curl command that has like the the credential or the header or whatever you know what i mean like
people are constantly copying and pasting a ton of stuff into their read me and their projects
yeah absolutely yeah i i love this man and i i hope um you know with how with how thorough sharon in the um
truffle stack team is with these sort of things i'm sure they did this well but um i i also
you know i hope that they're looking at you know binary format stuff too and and looking for more
than just um just these specific secrets because i know that one of the biggest boundaries i've ever
seen came from a leak like this and it was a auth certificate that was found in like this freaking
dot pyc file or something like that you know in a more binary format um yeah there's no way i would
publish this without giving myself like months to go through it so honestly there's probably a lot of
data and a lot of interesting things that could be found there like even if you're just a person who
knows about a secret format that's not in truffle hog right like go look right now because you can
probably go find you know exactly that yeah absolutely man good stuff by sharon as always in
the truffle sec team um all right next up uh was this one this is by zero um who we've been talking
about a lot on the pod just constantly cranking out good uh articles for us to discuss um this one is a
little bit more of a meta article though it's entitled bug bounty feedback strategy and alchemy um and
there's a couple points that i had throughout this one but i always enjoy reading excuse me bug bounty um
sort of meta articles because it talks about the way people think about the industry from a higher
perspective and can kind of elevate your thinking um quite a bit but uh you know one of the first things
and and i know you know this uh as well we've kind of talked about this many times one of the things he
he shouts out on here is this line however who you are what you degrees you hold who you know and
where you live doesn't matter in bug bounty no interviews no schedules no race to meet arbitrary
standards there are rules rewards a defined scope and a game you discover vulnerability within the rules
you earn a reward no ceiling no safety net only skill reigns and i and i was just like dude goosebumps man
like how lucky are we yeah to have this skill this thing that we love right this this hobby and then
be able to implement it in a way where we don't have to do sales we don't have to do there's infinite
demand for critical vulnerabilities right infinite demand no sales no meetings you can just sit down
and find bugs and that's it from anywhere counting no you don't like you don't need any overhead it's
like you need a laptop or a phone freaking unbelievable it is absolutely unbelievable um so i'm just so
blessed to be in this industry and i'm so excited uh and i and i i a lot of people ask me you know hey
what salary would you need to pull you away from bug bounty hunting and sure maybe there's a number
you know a couple million or something like that but where i would just work for a year and it should
be done and go back to bug bounty is that what you're saying and go back to bug bounty right you
know like yeah but but the thing is you know this is what i want to be doing this is exactly what i want to
be doing um i've been thinking a lot about that actually as like a really random aside on the meta
topic because it's this and then you can still mention other things from this blog post i feel
like i had some discontentment through the month of may and early june just feeling like i was like
leaving something on the table for some random reason and like i don't know i think that yeah honestly
might have been just a bad headspace but like every the thing that the grounding thing that brought me
back to it's like what would i do like if i just had way more money it's like oh i would just do bug
bounty hunting and like do critical thinking so i could hang out with justin it's like so why am i
trying to like you know maybe there's probably some other path to more money but guess what i'm not
willing to take those trade-offs because i'm already at the end right i don't need to get these other
means to an end because i'm at the end and so yeah and we've got the time and the flexibility that we
we need right i know that that's big for both of us getting time just you know to spend with the
kids to be able to help with stuff um and be able to do the research we love so freaking love it man me
too um for further along and well actually before we go into that i think just on that note i think
it's very important for full-time bug bounty hunters to relish the beauty of bug bounty and the
flexibility that it affords you so i've had a slow couple months since we won in tokyo right um and
i love it i loved it you know and this is one of the first times where i loved it you know where because
i guess over over the the time that i've been a full-time bug bounty hunter you know i've always
struggled a little bit with like i shouldn't take me down periods i'm not having getting revenue i'm not
working i'm not generating money but dude you know what screw it man this is exactly the time that i
want to be not working you know where i want to be spending time with my kids over the summer
or you know working on house projects or whatever i'm doing um those are the things that i want
to prioritize and like you said the money is there the money will come it's all good yeah i had to
remind myself like that this is the reason why you have runway and this is like what you expected
going into this like you knew there were going to be highs and lows and so the fact that you have
to you know touch a tiny bit of your runway is not like some massive loss it's like oh that's why i have it
but yeah exactly exactly man um yeah so anyway going back we took a tangent but going back to zeros right
up here um i always love seeing these characterizations of the hackers in the community right
um and he he says there are lots of different styles of hacking that can be successful he lists
the main app guy the recon guy the master automator the low-hanging fruit eater the architect the zero day
researcher the niche specialist the opportunist and the ai bot which i i thought was great um
and looking at each one of these uh i i think he lists more categories than most people do and it's
almost like personality tests like you could keep slicing it up different people have different
perspectives but it's still always kind of interesting and fun that's how i view it it's like
yeah some people fall in multiple categories some people have all the skills some people are
not going to fit these categories but i i always like reading them anyways and i think that they're
really fun to think about yeah i'm trying to find i can't find that write-up by kodingo but kodingo
also does a good article on the bug crowd blog sort of talking about the the recon guy the main
app guy or whatever um i really did like zero's representation of it though because um he says specifically
that he recommends the niche specialist and this is what he he um he says specializes in one type or
family of vulnerabilities and masters it better than you know x percent of the hunters finds what
others miss rises above the competition its relevance depends on a choice of specialization which i'll
come back to a little bit later if the choices are good it can obviously make money frequently
this is what i've recommended in the past um and yeah i think that's great you know going i mean
obviously this person is a uh specialist in cash poisoning related vulnerabilities so uh he's
definitely got some bias there uh you know but i think the niche specialist is always a really good
way to go if you want to start making money in bug bounty well i think there's a couple reasons why too
like one is the fact that uh you do have to it's a skill game right like we just talked about that
you have to beat out other people and so there's a couple ways that you can beat them out right like
if you wanted to be a recon guy or you want to be a low-hanging fruit you got to be faster
and you got to stay on top of other people right whereas if you just have if you're just the most
skilled in a specific thing not only can you find those by yourself but people will drive deals to you
right it's the same reason why people go to chapman for uh headless chrome bugs right it and there's
enough of you front-end guys where it's kind of dispersed but in general you will all get a lot of
people reaching out with front-end phones right i think that um it really helped me especially earlier
this year as people came to me whenever they were dealing with like ai phones and so i think that having a
doesn't exclude you from like spraying that specialty like let's say you're a big xss guy and you find
xss on like a third-party library or in like a a specific thing now you can spray it and you can
still be a recon person with your niche specialty um and you can grab low hanging fruit with your niche
specialty i think the niche specialist is like defensible against ai and also um useful because it
drives deals your way in the form of networking and collaborations but then also even if you didn't have
those you could just go find that bug other places and it's going to exist there because you're better
at finding it than other people so it's at a higher skill level so it's kind of withheld from the crowd
just for you absolutely man i love what you said but you lost me when you slapped your mic
i did listen i've been trying not to touch i've been muting it when i need to touch it i was told i
touched it too much in the past dude i i also touch my mic a lot so hey guys i'm sorry like like
richard we're so sorry listeners we're so sorry like we're we're hackers we're not podcasters so
uh richard does our does it the best he can with our like crap audio we give him where's our nito
yelling exactly dude i dude my nito broke my nito broke i can't squeeze it anymore so sad
anyway let's bring it back around um last little quote i wanted to read from this article um was this
one this one's a little bit longer but but hang in there okay so it says money has been discussed
a lot here nothing unusual from the perspective of a full-time independent bounty hunter uh but it's
time to aim higher to seek to move things forward in your field and do your part i find it fascinating
that much of the technology we use today is a result of vast of a vast stack of universal knowledge built
on over centuries by countless contributors narrowing it down you've probably reached this level thanks to
numerous research papers courses videos shared for free by people around the world aren't you in some way
indebted to that stack now it's your turn to contribute with research papers novel findings
presentations useful tools and simply some good advice if it worked for you it might work for others
too um i thought that dude i thought i was i was moved man i was moved a little bit in the heart you
know like we all are standing on the shoulders of giants in this industry and uh it has made me really
happy especially to see um some of the guys in the critical thinking community like like demo turbo right
um you know doing these talks at defcon or um you know there's lots of people contributing
back um and it's really let let me have my hot take then so i definitely agree i think that the
cyber security industry is extremely unique relative to other industries like i actually think that
um i actually think that it is more different and unique in this way than any other industry
like i don't think there's any other industry where people give back as much as they do every time
i'm every time i meet a security guy a security person who like goes to conferences all the time security
conferences and like does talks and stuff i'm always like kind of shocked and i'm almost off put by
the fact they do that for free like the vast majority of speakers at conferences are going to
these random conferences and so many of them are in little small towns and they're on the sidetrack
and they're presenting to 10 people who are never going to use their research and they still like
love to do it and they'd love to go and they put in hours into these like presentations and sometimes
they get on youtube and they do well or whatever like they go into the video archives and sometimes
people do find them and use them but i one think that's extremely impressive and really cool i also
think it creates a culture of not wanting to pay for information and so i i'm not like a course maker
right i've done one 200 course which was like very bleeding edge like information on like the zero to
hero of agent hacking but like outside of that i've done no courses and there are people who do like
really good courses and really good training and also like i think that there are a lot of speakers that
are good enough and i think are worthy of being paid to go places that like can't get paid to do it
because like the security industry is like so sharing so i don't know i don't know if there's
like a big fix for that i don't even know if it's a real complaint because i do think that is incredible
in a lot of ways but i also think that it does create an industry that is like really reticent to
pay for products and reticent to pay for because they're so pro open source also and so reticent to pay for
information that is that is a an interesting take on that you know i i think yeah it would it does affect you
know the ability to get paid for some of these things um but anyways i mean we also give a ton
of free information away every week here on critical thinking so and i and i love doing it
and it's a kind of it's a privilege it is that's right lots of fun man um that's all i had on my
list do you have anything else you wanted to throw on here at the end of the pod um yeah i'll just
throw in something really quick because i think it's so cool and incredible speaking of free information
actually wow i did not mean i did not intend this segue guys um but google released let me make sure
i pop down my messages before i share my screen i always accidentally share my twitter messages i have
to edit it out um so uh basically google released their entire playbook and project uh the entire paper
and all of the open source code for their prompt injection protection that they actually use across
their products i'm sure it's not 100 you know of what they're using but it is massively underrated
only 40 stars here with only six forks it was released three weeks ago and it is like uh their
paper defeat defeating prompt injection by design which you know we've uh encountered a lot in our
hacking and how how good they are at defending prompt injection relative to other um other companies and
other organizations and it's by using a thing called camel which stands for something i don't even know
what it stands for but um but anyways they released um this repo that shows how to use it and all
that and when they released this i was like kind of blown away that they had released it because
this feels like the bleeding edge like the you know frontline best research for prompt injection
protection at scale and so if you're a company out there or even if you're a hacker i think diving
into this would be a really uh worthwhile endeavor yeah totally man this uh i'm very surprised they
put this out yeah that's uh that's really cool definitely something i feel like ronnie has already like
consumed red and concerned you know yeah uh after struggling with that for so long at the at the event
yeah so very fun all right man uh that's a wrap on this one um cool stuff i i i enjoyed today's episode
i was i was not gonna lie i was a little tight anytime we record an episode after i do the hack along
you know and i felt a little drained this morning i you know my social energy is low and i'm like trying
to turtle up a little bit but this is a good one yeah you did well thanks man thanks guys peace peace
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end
y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctvb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high-level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild
if you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there